MORNING.
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT WE'VE FOUND.
AS SOON AS WE LEAVE OUR
COMPOUND, IT'S CLEAR WHO IS NOW
IN CHARGE.
TALIBAN FIGHTERS HAVE FLOODED
THE CAPITAL, SMILING AND
VICTORIOUS, THEY TOOK THE CITY
OF 6 MILLION PEOPLE IN A MATTER
OF HOURS.
BARELY FIRING A SHOT.
THIS IS A SIGHT I HONESTLY
THOUGHT I WOULD NEVER SEE,
SCORES OF TALIBAN FIGHTERS AND
JUST BEHIND US, THE U.S. EMBASSY
COMPOUND.
SOME CARRY AMERICAN WEAPONS.
THEY TELL US THEY'RE HERE TO
MAINTAIN LAW AND ORDER.
EVERYTHING IS UNDER CONTROL.
EVERYTHING WILL BE FINE, THE
COMMANDER SAYS.
NOBODY SHOULD WORRY.
WHAT'S YOUR MESSAGE TO AMERICA
RIGHT NOW?
AMERICA ALREADY SPENT ENOUGH
TIME IN AFGHANISTAN.
THEY NEED TO LEAVE, HE TELLS US.
THEY ALREADY LOST LOTS OF LIVES
AND LOTS OF MONEY.
PEOPLE COME UP TO THEM TO POSE
FOR PHOTOGRAPHS.
THEY'RE JUST CHANTING DEATH TO
AMERICA, BUT THEY SEEM FRIENDLY
AT THE SAME TIME.
IT'S UTTERLY BIZARRE.
AT THE PRESIDENTIAL PALACE, THE
TALIBAN ARE NOW GUARDING THE
GATE.
THEY SAY THEY'RE HERE TO FILL
THE VACUUM LEFT WHEN THE
GOVERNMENT FLOOD.
BUT THE WELCOMING SPIRIT ONLY
EXTENDS SO FAR.
AND MY PRESENCE SOON CREATES
TENSION.
>> BECAUSE OF YOU --
>> THEY JUST TOLD ME TO STAND TO
THE SIDE BECAUSE I'M A WOMAN.
OUTSIDE, ORDINARY AFGHANS
CLAMBER TO TALK TO US.
STRUGGLING TO PROCESS THE
DIZZYING SPEED OF KABUL'S FALL.
>> ACTUALLY, I FEEL NOTHING
RIGHT NOW.
WE WANT PEACE.
WE ARE TIRED OF THIS ON GOING
WAR.
WHAT DOES THE FEATURE LOOK LIKE
TO YOU NOW?
>> YOU KNOW, I CANNOT PREDICT
EVEN IN SECONDS RIGHT NOW AND
CAN'T PREDICT MINUTES RIGHT NOW.
SO THAT'S WHY I DON'T KNOW WHAT
WILL HAPPEN TOMORROW, WHAT WILL
HAPPEN AFTER.
>> Reporter: YOU KNOW, IN MANY
WAYS, JOHN AND BRIANNA, THE
STORY TODAY IS ABOUT THE PEOPLE
WHO AREN'T OUT ON THE STREETS,
WHO DON'T FEEL SAFE, WHO ARE
PETRIFIED, WHO ARE WONDERING
WHAT THE FUTURE WILL BRING WHO
ARE HIDING OUT.
THERE ARE TENS OF THOUSANDS, IF
NOT HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS, OF
THEM ACROSS THIS CITY.
WE CAN'T SEE THEM AND THEY'RE
NOT SPEAKING BECAUSE THEY'RE SO
CONCERNED THEIR VOICES ARE
LARGELY SILENT, BUT STILL WHEN
YOU THINK OF THOSE IMAGES AT THE
AIRPORT, YOU HAVE TO KEEP THOSE
IN YOUR MIND.
THAT IS THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
COIN HERE, THE DARK REALITY OF
THE ABSOLUTE BITTER FEAR THAT IS
CONSUMING SO MANY AFGHANS IN
THIS NEW, BIZARRE WORLD.
>> THAT'S REALLY THE DESCRIPTION
COMING FROM INSIDE OF
AFGHANISTAN, CLARISSA.
I WAS TRYING TO HAVE SOME WOMEN
WHO ARE HOLED UP THERE IN
AFGHANISTAN ON THE SHOW TODAY
TRYING TO BOOK THEM ON THE SHOW
THROUGH AN AFGHAN-AMERICAN
COUSIN WHO IS HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES, BUT THEY'RE JUST TOO
TERRIFIED.
THEY'RE TOO TERRIFIED TO COME ON
EVEN WITH THE PROMISE OF
OBSCURING THEIR VOICES AND THEIR
IDENTITIES AND RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
HOLED UP IN THEIR HOUSE.
THE TALIBAN IS WALKING OUTSIDE
OF THEIR HOUSE AND THEY WORRY
IT'S A MATTER OF TIME UNTIL
SOMEONE KNOCKS ON THE DOOR.
>> Reporter: AND ABSOLUTELY.
ESPECIALLY FOR WOMEN WHO HAVE
BEEN OUTSPOKEN, FOR WOMEN WHO
HAVE HAD PROMINENT JOBS, WOMEN
IN POLITICS, WOMEN IN THE
JUDICIARY, FEMALE JOURNALISTS,
ALL OF THESE WOMEN, INCREDIBLY
STRONG, BRILLIANT WOMEN ARE
RIGHT NOW ABSOLUTELY PETRIFIED,
WAITING TO SEE WHAT WILL HAPPEN?
WHERE CAN THEY TURN?
WHERE CAN THEY GO?
WILL THEY BECOME A TARGET?
>> CLARISSA, WE'RE LOOKING AT
SCENES FROM THE AIRPORT IN
KABUL.
OBVIOUSLY THE FRENZY OF PEOPLE
TRYING TO GET ON PLANES THERE.
BUT CAN PEOPLE EVEN GET TO THE
AIRPORT AT THIS POINT?
>> Reporter: SO WE HAD SEVERAL
TEAMS OF COLLEAGUES WHO TRIED TO
GET TO THE AIRPORT YESTERDAY.
AND IT WAS MAYHEM.
ESSENTIALLY THE ENTIRE ROAD WAS
COMPLETELY BLOCKED WITH CAR.
YOU HAD PEOPLE DRIVING DOWN THE
WRONG SIDE OF THE ROAD.
ONE AMERICAN FRIEND TOLD ME
THERE WERE SCENES OF CHAOS, THIS
CRUSH OF PEOPLE TRYING TO GET
THROUGH AND THEN THERE WAS
SHOOTING.
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHETHER THE
SHOOTING WAS TARGETING SOMEBODY
OR WHETHER IT WAS SIMPLY SOMEONE
TRYING TO SCATTER THE CROWD
BECAUSE THE CHAOS WAS TOO MUCH.
BUT, AS YOU WELL KNOW, WHEN EVER
YOU HAVE A SCENE LIKE THAT WHERE
YOU HAVE A CRASH OF HUMANITY,
WHERE YOU HAVE ABSOLUTE CHAOS,
WHERE YOU HAVE BULLETS FLYING,
THAT'S WHEN PEOPLE GET HURT.
AND I THINK THOSE IMAGES THAT
YOU'RE SEEING, THEY'RE SEARED
INTO ALL OF OUR MINDS, SPEAK TO
THIS DESPERATION, HOW DESPERATE,
HOW PETRIFIED DOES AN INDIVIDUAL
HAVE TO BE TO RISK EVERYTHING
AND JUST TRY TO PHYSICALLY CRUSH
YOURSELF ON TO THE OUTSIDE OF AN
AIRPLANE?
THOSE IMAGES OF PEOPLE HOLDING
ON TO A U.S. AIR FORCE CARRIER.
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING MANY
AMERICANS WILL -- PEOPLE AROUND
THE WORLD WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
GET OUT OF THEIR MINDS FOR QUITE
SOME TIME.
>> YEAH.
THEY ARE RISKING DEATH BECAUSE
THEY'RE CERTAIN THEY'RE GOING TO
FACE IT THERE IN KABUL.
I WONDER, CLARISSA, WHAT WILL
BECOME OF THE U.S. EMBASSY NOW
THAT AMERICANS HAVE LEFT?
IS THERE A POSSIBILITY WE COULD
BE SEEING A TALIBAN FLAG FLYING
OVER THE EMBASSY?
ARE THERE SECURITY FORCES TO
STOP SOMETHING LIKE THAT
HAPPENING?
>> Reporter: WE DIDN'T SEE ANY
INDICATION OF SECURITY FORCES
THERE.
LOOK AT WHAT THE TALIBAN DID
LAST NIGHT IN THE PRESIDENTIAL
PALACE.
HOURS AFTER ASHRAF GHANI FLED
THE COUNTRY, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, THEY WERE IN THERE
ASSERTING THEMSELVES, HOLDING
COURT.
I SHOULD SAY THESE ARE MOSTLY
COMMANDERS AND FIGHTERS.
WE HAVE YET TO SORT OF HAVE THE
ARRIVAL LET'S SAY OF THE MORE
SEASONED TALIBAN POLITICAL
LEADERS.
AND I THINK THEY WILL BE TRYING
TO CALL THE SHOTS WITH AN EYE ON
WHAT THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY
WILL BE THINKING AND MAKING OF
THIS WHOLE SITUATION.
BUT IT IS CERTAINLY QUITE
POSSIBLE THAT YOU WILL SEE THE
TALIBAN ENTER THE U.S. EMBASSY,
CERTAINLY THERE'S NO REAL WAY AT
THIS STAGE TO STOP IT.
>> NO, BECAUSE THE U.S. HAS
COMPLETELY EVACUATED SAID
EMBASSY.
I GUESS REALLY IMPORTANT
QUESTION OVER THE NEXT FEW DAYS,
CLARISSA, IS WHAT ARE THE
TALIBAN'S INTENTIONS TOWARD THE
AIRPORT, WITH THE AIRPORT, WITH
THE ONE REMAINING SITE WHERE
PEOPLE CAN GET OUT?
>> Reporter: I THINK FOR NOW THE
TALIBAN IS HAPPY FOR THE AIRPORT
TO BE UNDER THE PURVIEW OF THE
U.S. FOR AS LONG AS THOSE
EVACUATIONS ARE GOING ON.
IN A STRANGE SENSE, THEY DON'T
WANT TO DO ANYTHING THAT WOULD
IMPEDE THOSE EVACUATIONS BECAUSE
THEY WANT ALL FOREIGNERS OUT OF
THIS COUNTRY.
THEY SAID AS MUCH TO MANY MANY
TIMES ON THE STREETS TODAY.
SO, THERE IS A SORT OF THRESHOLD
OF PATIENCE WHEREBY THEY'RE
WILLING TO WAIT OUT THE NEXT
COUPLE OF DAYS UNTIL THOSE
EVACUATIONS ARE COMPLETE.
BUT ONE CAN ONLY ASSUME THAT AT
SOME POINT THEY WILL VERY MUCH
WANT THOSE 6,000 U.S. TROOPS TO
LEAVE AS WELL AS, YOU KNOW, SOME
VARIOUS BRITISH AND OTHER
NATIONALITIES MILITARY WHO ARE
ALSO HERE EVACUATING THEIR OWN
CITIZENS.
WE DON'T KNOW YET, THOUGH, WHAT
THE TALIBAN'S TIMELINE IS FOR
THAT.
THEY HAVE SAID THEY WILL NOT
DECLARE AN INTERIM GOVERNMENT, A
TRANSITIONAL GOVERNMENT UNTIL
EVERYBODY IS OUT.
>> AS YOU MENTIONED, CLARISSA,
YOUR DRESS CODE HAS CLEARLY
CHANGED HERE IN THE LAST DAY
SINCE THE TALIBAN TOOK OVER
KABUL.
IS IT SAFE THERE?
IS IT LESS SAFE FOR YOU?
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE REPORTING FROM
THE STREET, BUT WHAT ARE
CONSIDERATIONS RIGHT NOW FOR
FOREIGN JOURNALISTS LIKE
YOURSELF?
>> Reporter: WELL, WE'VE BEEN
TOLD WE'RE FREE TO REPORT HERE.
WE'RE VERY CAUTIOUS.
WE HAVE GOOD LINES INTO THE
TALIBAN.
ANY TIME WE WANT TO SHOOT VIDEO
ON THE STREET, WE'LL STOP AND GO
AND ASK THEM.
FOR THE MOST PART IT HASN'T BEEN
A PROBLEM.
OCCASIONALLY MY GENDER DOES FLUM
MEX THEM.
AT THE ENTRANCE TO THE
PRESIDENTIAL PALACE IT WAS
UNCOMFORTABLE MOMENT THEY WERE
SHOEING ME AWAY AND ASKING WHY
MY COLLEAGUES BROUGHT A WOMAN
WITH THEM, WHICH IS FRANKLY TO
BE EXPECTED AND NOT UNUSUAL.
I WILL SAY ALSO, BRIANNA, A LOT
LESS WOMEN ON THE STREETS TODAY.
NORMALLY KABUL IT'S STILL A
CONSERVATIVE SOCIETY.
WOMEN DO WEAR THE HEAD SCARF,
BUT NOT QUITE AS TIGHTLY AS
THIS.
YOU MIGHT SEE THEM WITH SOME
HAIR SHOWING OR COLORS.
YOU MIGHT SEE THEM WEARING
SLIGHTLY MORE SHAPELY
SILHOUET